las relaciones con áfrica ocuparon un
papel central en los cinco años de
mandato de manuel ma con recién
posesionado el presidente francés
prometía un profundo viraje ahora sus
aciertos y errores podrían influir en su
imagen como líder mayor buscó demostrar
una cierta modernidad buscó dialogar con
la juventud africana y buscó gente e
insistir en su juventud en el hecho de
que él no había conocido la del tiempo
de la colonización pero ha sido
problemático porque hubo sea estas
fuertes adicciones contradicciones que
se vieron reflejadas en la presencia de
militares franceses en sus ex colonias
africanas a pesar del retiro de las
fuerzas en mali francia no abandona su
influencia militar en el sahel o
salvárcar e no se va a ver de malí
porque los franceses lo pidan porque los
malienses lo pidan sabar cannes se va de
malí porque es una operación que no
funciona que no tiene resultados de
naturaleza de la barca ni esposa es
controvertida
se ven de que hay una serie de grupos
terroristas pero desde la población
local la palabra terrorista no existe en
las lenguas locales la carrera al elíseo
sea en medio de una importante y tú la
conmemoración del aniversario de los 60
años del fin de la guerra en argelia a
cuyos ex combatientes marco buscó
reconocer y reparar una buena parte de
los electores bien oa los pies negros es
decir
franceses nacidos en argelia que han
tenido que volver de volverse para la
metrópolis que van a participar en las
elecciones constituyen pues una parte
importante pero tampoco es
insignificante del electorado en plena
campaña electoral los candidatos toman
el peso del imaginario francés sobre sus
ex colonias como bandera para los
candidatos de derecha de extrema derecha
temas centrales el tema de la migración
estos candidatos insisten en no recibir
nueva acoger logró antes que provienen
del continente africano de un punto a
los candidatos de izquierda hay sobre
todo a una realidad de ruptura con la
acción solubilidad del intervencionismo
militar de francia el próximo líder
francés se enfrentará no sólo a las
heridas del pasado colonial sino también
a los retos del futuro un continente
dolido en la era post pandemia por haber
sido relegado en la vacunación y en el
que cada vez más otras potencias como
china y rúsia ganan influencia